this video was not sponsored by blistex
okay let me see if this is live now it
should be live
if you can see this type some obscure
90s reference that no one's thought
about in years to show that i'm down to
earth and relatable but i'm in fact an
anti-social pretentious germaphobic
hermit
okay great
alright let's get to the ranking of the
toes now john vervicky see i don't think
he uses enough specialized terminology
that only three people understand it's a
bit too simplified for my taste
i personally like a man whose main
content is like a prologue to the
glossary of that content repeat after me
john not every question needs to be
answered with the phrase relevance
realization
on the plus side though at least you've
given some words to pejo and vander clay
so that they can feel as if they're
being scientific when they quote you
see
thomas campbell all right thomas
campbell reminds you of the guy who
would hand out unwrapped fruit on
halloween
like your friend who doesn't wear socks
and has beads instead of bedroom doors
it's a brilliant man who has a degree in
nuclear physics and i think should have
an honorary one in drug development as
doctors now prescribe listening to my
big toe for insomnia
be
[Music]
now speaking of people who rely on their
former physics degree to give them an
air of credibility
kurt jaimungle if i had a nickel for
every time kurt said explication or
interjected with some mathematical fact
that no one cares about then i wouldn't
have to mention patreon like it wasn't
overbearing the first 280 times kurt
jaimungal or as he's affectionately
nicknamed what would happen if lex
friedman and jordan peterson had an
unsuccessful brown baby
kurt's opinion of himself versus
subscriber count looks like that graph
of productivity versus wage stagnation
a man with the charisma of peppa pig
is the only man to have pulled his back
from furrowing his brows
the guy whose career trajectory should
be followed by the theme from curb your
enthusiasm
he looks like a bollywood extra just
waiting for that big break
d
bernardo castro now on video bernardo's
wonderful he's a great friend but for
some reason it's impossible to take a
picture of him without it looking like
it should be followed by and tonight on
to catch a predator
c
yoshibok now yoshibok has won awards on
cognitive architecture and mental
representations and for his work on
being the only person that makes eric
weinstein sound comprehensible speaking
to yosha is like speaking to gpt 3 with
the prompt export text that sounds
profound by utilizing rapidly uttered
obscure computer science analogies said
so self-assuredly that you feel foolish
for disagreeing so you publicly pretend
that it's genius but can't explain why
c
carl fristin now you have to respect
someone who can make trying to
understand the free energy principle
like trying to understand the opening
sequence of rick and morty on acid
speaking of acid the ogre now leo
answers the question of what would
happen if lsd gave you more of an ego
be steven pinker now anyone who goes to
the barber and the barber's like oh
you're giving me a dollar tip ahead of
time no sir i'm just trying to show you
the haircut that i want that man
deserves an a
b
linda moulton howe now my major regret
with this video was that i wasn't
critical enough with her we got along a
bit too well i didn't impudently and
cringely question her credibility
several times in a row
that's okay at least her leather jacket
will become a regular
c
speaking of regulars gnome chomsky the
person who's been on toe more than any
other guest personally
i don't think he deserved what snape did
to him at the end of half-blood prince
but that's just my bias
travis walton they say they made a true
life story of his account in the 90s it
rhymes with ire i
i think it started jim carrey
i'm not sure no i'm just kidding i'm
just kidding it's fire fire right right
fire in the sky okay that's a huge
accomplishment i remember because it was
the only film to lose critically to
don't mess with the zohan that's
difficult
c
brian keating now i learned so much from
brian as a podcaster like that it
doesn't matter how many times you ask
people to like and subscribe
it doesn't work
i'm just kidding man i'm kidding brian
taught me that the best way to get back
at the nobel committee is to repeatedly
validate them by interviewing as many
nobel winners as possible i'm just
kidding man i'm kidding you have to have
a sense of humor in this podcast
industry especially when you have a face
like fred flintstone like i'm i'm
kidding man i'm kidding buzz lightyear
has supported me since near the
beginning and i'm lucky to call him a
friend
wow thanks kurt
hey
lee cronin now lee looks and sounds like
a classy mad scientist from a b movie in
the 80s where he's continually pointing
out some alarming news that others
aren't listening to but you don't
understand the assembly number is too
high
okay
we understand lee we understand that you
think physicists don't understand
entropy because you don't we get it
ross coldheart now i tell you what i
think but i truly think it's best you
just read about it in this book
this is one of the big problems for me
when i was writing my my book i've
worked at
ways of doing this in the course of my
research for the book a few of them have
become aware that i've written a book
but if you can give it to people yeah
whoever
actually actually if he reads my book i
write about them in the book so that
freaked you out
he oh there's so many interviews you can
i mean i don't want to sound like i'm
overly promoting my book but you know
i've detailed them in my book in all
seriousness you have to respect a man
who's gone from award-winning 60 minutes
journalist dining with prime ministers
to rummaging around tom delong's
basement looking for a piece of bismuth
metal made from a car in 1922.
look i'm just kidding ross is a dear
friend you can find ross on youtube on
amazon and on pornhub considering how
badly he used his future prospects by
investigating e.t
[Applause]
hey chris langan now that's an ester i
mean the ctmu it's a super tyratology it
syntactically includes all the other
tears
true true genius i feel my iq increasing
just looking at him
yes now if you want to decrease your iq
tom de long no i'm just kidding a man
whose name said quickly sounds like ikea
cutlery
the difference between tom and cutlery
at least is that the cutlery has a point
i mean m c escher himself couldn't make
something more contradictory than secret
machines but tom is important because we
need someone that even richard dodie is
like
that's a bit too far
c
okay don hoffman versus yoshibak
this was like watching daigo versus chun
li
[Applause]
by the way if you get that reference
then i feel sorry for you
be
a nail set or in other words what
happens when the kid from avatar the
last airbender grows up and gets famous
from a ted talk
richie doland
i like that he studies ufos but doesn't
fall into that typical conspiracy rabbit
hole
he's truly a unique individual he's
right people incorrectly stereotype him
i think we'd all be surprised if he
didn't have a x-files themed ringtone
and a picture of lazar pleasuring favor
as his wallpaper
b
carlo revelli relational quantum
mechanics not a man of absolutes to him
o kelvin is a term of endearment like oh
kelvin come on carlo is famous for
saying it's relations all the way down
which i think he adopted from
metaphysically interpreting bill clinton
yes
lou elizondo now what i like about lou
is that he's clear doesn't hide behind
his nda like most people doesn't go on a
tangent about
unrelated metaphors for nine minutes
it's just straight facts
hey
rupert spyra where is the border of your
experience kurt
hey man people are wondering where the
border of this conversation is it's been
like three and a half hours time is
money i'm just kidding man it's a
pleasure and a gift to be able to spend
this much time with the man that people
go to because they can't afford eckhart
tolle
this
david wallpark has about six no-go
theorems restricting him from being
placed at any level below b
stephen wolfram see i don't know how
steven can stand being in an industry
with all these overly opinionated and
egotistical business owners it just
doesn't fit
now the hallmark of a great theory is
when it's so specific that it can be
falsified i asked him general relativity
with the negative cosmological constant
stephen's like i can derive that
positive cosmological concept i i can
derive that
an underrivable girdle-like statement oh
yes yes easily yes
the nazgul from lord of the rings
most likely
how about a theories of everything
channel with more than six women in it
now that's a bit tricky kurt
b
ian mcgillcrist one of the best
interviews on this channel i always like
a book that you can pick up and finish
in three years
ian given the expansion of the universe
by the time people read this there won't
be any matter or things my left
hemisphere wants to rate this an s and
my right hemisphere wants to commiserate
with you for not being able to get a
word in edgewise with jordan peterson jp
stop
lastly don hoffman
i am still not sure if his message is
related to space-time being doomed
perhaps he should reiterate that another
550 times
don i love your prolificness i love how
you're constantly innovating and by
innovating what i mean is you find 15
different ways of saying the same thing
constantly new inspiring what's next don
are you going to talk about how the
particle goes through both slits but
only when no one's watching
well
given how many people i've offended
lately perhaps
soon i'll be able to let you know what
it's like to go through both as well
oh and that alan watts curt girdle theo
locution
terrible match one of the worst podcasts
on this channel no one wanted to see
that d
this is a note from kurt these were just
april fool's jokes i love and appreciate
every one of the guests on this channel
and i still can't believe how lucky and
blessed i am to be able to spend even 10
minutes with each of these people
what an honor rupert spyra tom delong
stephen wolfram bernardo castro yoshibok
thomas campbell leo gura pinker chris
langan linda hal anil seth ross
coldheart don hoffman lee cronin lou
elizondo ian mcgilchrist brian keating
to name a few thank you for coming on to
the theories of everything podcast the
channel and the broader world was and is
improved merely by your presence and
we're extremely grateful for your time
thank you dearly
if you're interested in continuing to
laugh at toe related aspects then visit
the subreddit kirchheim uncle memes
which is run by user not my account
slash jack
who supplied some of the graphics for
these jokes here are a few
[Music]
this podcast is now finished if you'd
like to hear me supplicate for another
few seconds then continue listening to
my 100 not repetitive plead for
donations it's support from the patrons
aka the splendid and munificent and the
sponsors aka those brave enough to
invest in a channel on mathematical
physics consciousness and god teetering
as close as you can to being deepak
chopra without being deepak that allow
me to do this full time every dollar
helps tremendously thank you
[Music]
you